dawn breaks over the Indian Ocean
revealing the remote hassle of Alphonse
in the outer Seychelles the waves
breaking on its fringe reef it's the
first stop for the deep ocean explorers
of the nekton mission engineers have
been finalizing the submersibles for
launch
fixing specimen collection boxes on the
outside and ensuring a watertight
connection in the spaghetti of cables
that distribute power and control
signals around the subs seawater starts
wreaking havoc on all the electronics if
everything's got to work in order to
pull off the science and the media
mission so we have to be meticulous
about every step of the way not to
mention the life-support aspect
safety is paramount the mother ship on a
surface can track the subs depth and
position if there's a major power
failure there's emergency oxygen to last
96 hours underwater we'll be going down
to 300 metres as far as this sub can
safely go at that depth that pressure is
immense equivalent to a jumbo jet
pressing on your head and our very
survival depends on this bubble of
acrylic plastic 8 centimetres thick
technology from around the world is
having to be meshed together to pull off
deep ocean live a series of pioneering
programs will broadcast from the
Twilight Zone plugs and sockets don't
always match
so there's resoled ring to do but Randy
who's done more than 350 dives some as
deep as 1,000 meters says it'll all be
worth while it's peaceful you know if
it's a flat bottom we can land there I
actually enjoy turning lights off
turning down some of the noisy systems
and just sitting in the quiet and the
darkness and just watching what happens
the bioluminescence will come by and
we'll be sparkles you can hear the
shrimp crack
bulging the two million pound machines
looks precarious but practice will make
the operation slicker they're also
technical problems on the subs to solve
became another
but our engineer who has rigged them
with cameras is happy the pictures from
the deep will be spectacular Thomas More
Sky News in the Seychelles in the deep
ocean life series will broadcasts live
news bulletins 300 feet underwater
Girona spinny Fosse on Monday the 18th
Tuesday the 19th and Wednesday the 20th
of March you can also keep up to date
with our deep ocean teams on the sky
news website and of course from the
mobile app